now we're all sleeping in one room next
to a cow orgy I'd much rather be hanging
out with you what are you doing Boyle
just brushing my hair not you Becca I
was talking to Charles I was just
bringing you some water thanks so uh
who you talking to is that your mystery
hunk
it's fine I'll call you back later is
that a woman's voice it's my sister wait
she called you babe when my cousin
called me babe you said relatives
shouldn't do that
what's really going on
I'm dating a woman
I'm bi oh that's great
that's great Rose I just want you to
know that I totally support I want to
talk about it right now okay just leave
it alone Boy by all means not you Becca
okay I love you I love you too hey hey
so I didn't say anything about being by
because I didn't think it was anybody's
business
and I also didn't want anything to
change I get it I'm sorry so nosy
actually felt really good to tell
somebody on the squad finally
I'm glad it was you all right
also now we go back to never talking
about my love life again uh request
tonight is your name Anne Meredith Kim
Erica okay quick update on the Warren
Street break in security cameras caught
a picture of the suspect and guess what
that's right we got a hot purple alert
I'd like to bring that guy to Justice we
all would but unfortunately police
cornered him and he shot himself in the
face
thank you for that shockingly dark
update anything else uh yes
something I'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but
here we go
I'm bisexual all right I will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go Amy how long have
you known since seventh grade I was
watching Saved by the Bell and I thought
Zack Morris is hot and then I thought
Lisa Turtle also hot the fact that the
words Kelly and capacity didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now Charles
found out on the road trip and I was
positive he was not going to be able to
keep a secret for much longer bye Rosa
I mean not bye but bye I mean see ya I
mean have fun only having sex with men
just banging dudes left and right I just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
Tiffany are you lying about her name so
we want to look her up yes I am next do
you know Anne Heche I do oh I must say
this is going considerably better than
when I came out to my colleagues they
were not as the kids say awake do you
mean woke I didn't mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent okay we have
time for one more question no no
absolutely not we're done
smart it was not tasty I didn't know
Jake was joining us neither did I what a
fun surprise that none of us were
remotely prepared for Rosa right you
seem nervous why uh
global warming what a [ __ ] right we all
go and drown anyways I'm gonna head to
the bathroom for the duration of one
conversation nope
uh guys I have something I need to tell
you what is it honey uh Jake you take it
seriously me oh man now I really do have
to go to the bathroom well you didn't
before you lied you know Oscar most
people just ignore my nervous rambling
maybe [ __ ] Focus back to Rosa don't
worry we know what's happening you do of
course
you and Jake are dating that's why you
were nervous because you know I never
liked him what okay first of all that's
insane we've only met once and we
totally hit it off we talked about
soccer I called it football oh I see
what happened but secondly Rosa and I
are not denying that we're dating uh
you're right we're a couple I love you
honey bun
so how did you two finally get together
after all these years oh uh you know you
know I've just been crazy about her
forever and then one day I picked up my
battered old guitar and I sang her a
song
how did it go oh you don't want to hear
it yes I do well I don't have my guitar
here sing the song
you are so cool sounds better with a
guitar
just put that away who was that in the
picture just my mom kind of looked like
your co-worker Amy she can name your
friends it's not weird he had his arm
around her and she was showing off a
ring wow you got a really good look at
that picture huh what's going on
taking him you're engaged
that's okay what you got understand
love is complicated why would you be
okay with that when you call this dinner
you were so nervous we were worried you
were gonna tell us you were gay
so you would rather me be
some dude's mistress than be in a loving
relationship with a woman
well
Jake and I aren't dating but guess what
your worst fears are real I'm not
straight I'm bisexual and I don't care
what you think about it screw this I'm
out of here
I'm also gonna go are you guys on venmo
you know what we'll figure out later
this isn't the right time all right I'm
sorry things didn't go how you wanted
with your parents it was fine Rosie you
don't have to say that no it really did
go fine they texted me last night
don't worry about dinner see you at game
night nice
but very surprising it's great I told
him bye and they still invited me to
game night they're clearly okay with it
well I'm just glad it worked out enjoy
game night actually they want you to
come to make up for how awkward dinner
was oh fantastic I'm still involved well
I'm sure your dad is a super chill guy
to play against he is not well then
let's hope I'm on his team that is worse
cool so no good options super stoked
about this invite
so your mother and I talked about what
you told us last night we don't need to
talk about that right now we want you to
know we're not upset great I'm not upset
either because no matter what you call
yourself you still like men so you can
still get married and have a child you
can do those things with either a man or
a woman yes but it will be a man because
this is just a phase
okay that's settled ladies though
uh for a woman
a lady
uh women two women they're holding hands
uh friends
um uh sisters oh business partners oh um
oh oh oh co-owners of a chocolate shop
oh love love what do women love that
George Clooney it's a wedding
they're Brides they're in love
Mom Dad I know you don't want to talk
about this but I do I might get married
to a man like you so clearly want and I
might not because this is not a phase
and I need you to understand that
I'm bisexual there's no such thing as
being bisexual yes there is
I know there is because that's who I am
I'm attracted to both men and women
I've known this about myself for a
really long time and I didn't want to
tell you because I was afraid you were
going to react exactly like you are
what do you want us to say
you accept me for who I am
wow
okay let's go
foreign
[Music]
yes you should be very proud of yourself
I know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now but uh I promise
you they will improve thank you Captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are
the world becomes a better more
interesting place
so
thank you
you're so nice oh I don't know about
that Jocelyn I'm just being myself well
you're very sweet about the cosmetology
thing A lot of people are dismissive of
hair stylists it makes no sense if we
didn't have a hair stylist to cut our
hair our hair would be far too long wow
great compliment hey you're the girl
from the diarrhea commercial aren't you
you get diarrhea on the plane that's not
true yeah move along I don't get
diarrhea on the plane I get diarrhea in
the airport
what's going on are you
well you don't have to sound so grossed
out I can see why you didn't want him
meeting Jocelyn excuse me this isn't
Jocelyn it's Sheena she's an actress
yeah I was in an episode of SVU I say we
want answers the director tried to
replace me but Marishka said it would
take too much time and then they all
agreed I'd probably cut together fine
but yes I've obviously misread our
relationship you didn't want me to meet
the real Jocelyn because we're not as
close as I thought we were
message received
hey so you don't by any chance need any
Molly do you I'm a cop and a scene now I
am out of character and I don't sell any
drugs I am leaving
excuse me do you feel less crinkly
dollar I could trade you for of course I
do none of my dollars has a single
crinkle when they do I steam them oh
that is crisp can't wait to get this
baby home and flatten it out
almonds nice stories oh thanks they're
uh they're not for me they're for my
girlfriend detective Diaz oh you must be
Jocelyn what no I'm Denise who's Jocelyn
is Rosa cheating on me oh my no that was
a joke I'm sorry I thought it would be
funny I am Jocelyn oh that was actually
very funny I didn't know what was
happening and then I thought I knew what
was happening but what I thought I knew
was happening wasn't what was happening
it's very good you must be Captain Holt
hey hey uh can you give us a second baby
yeah wait out there pleasure meeting you
captain
oh
so this is Jocelyn I'm glad you got to
meet her for the record I wasn't keeping
her from you because I was afraid you
were going to hurt her feelings about
being judgy I think it's hilarious when
you're judgy it's because I was afraid
you weren't gonna like her you and I are
close and I
I value your opinion well she seems
great and our limited interaction maybe
you could get to know her better over
Kevin's rice this weekend that would be
great
you might want to save your girlfriend
she's talking to Hitchcock damn it
Hitchcock